great thanks
um so today we're going to talk about
conor forge
and how we support the growth of the
community during project
and i'm here joined with heimer one of
my colleagues at coinside and wolf at
the city of quan stack so i think we're
gonna go ahead
for almost directions oh yes of course
yes we did okay
you wanna say something real quick with
yourself yeah hi i'm wolf uh cto at
quantec and initiator of the mamba
project and also working a lot on
packaging all of the ros robotics
ecosystem as conor packages
i'll take over this one
so i i'm jaime uh i've been working with
econ ecosystem for a few years as a user
because it enabled my research as a phd
student
and basically i didn't have to depend on
it anymore which you know it frees some
ties
and then um i loved the ecosystem and i
kept contributing so today i'm giving a
talk with these two monsters about uh
so that's cool i think
so but i don't know if you're very
familiar with conda maybe if you have
heard about that gigantic booth i'm
econo has said so it's all about that so
the outline today will be about what
it's gonna forge and what it means to
users how it's organized and maintained
and then how it success is pushing for
innovation in the community and what's
the future for the connector system
after that
so okay
who here knows what conda is have you
ever used conda
wow
okay
um
who has suffered through his performance
who do you think
so some historical context for conda
let's go to the bc times before conduct
existed
so
you have to be really lucky or
very stubborn to make things work right
if you wanted to install python across
platforms
you needed maybe user permissions
because the default paths were going to
like the admin places
compiled extensions good luck
especially on windows if you don't have
the compiler setup which
then that wouldn't work then an anaconda
then called continuum analytics comes
and drops conda like hey we solved all
of that for you and it's like wow so it
immediately got a success
because
the conduct package format itself was
thought about
a pre-compiled binary so you don't have
to depend on compilers at all
language agnostic the structure of the
package you can see on the right side
is it doesn't really have to be about
python only even it's if it's python
focus right
you can install this is the recipe for
core utils the package for core youtube
so all your
unix binaries are there under bin you
have some metadata but basically it's
the linux prefix
with some extra stuff
again no permissions needed it features
a conda a package manager for dependency
solving
and you could install it with single
clicks or single step
instructions so you don't have to like
kill a process to let the completion
finish it was the case back then
and
pip and pipi wheels were not quite there
yet so it wasn't as
easy to install things without compiling
if you wanted to install an empire
sci-fi again good
luck so
this however introduced more problems
now anaconda continuum analytics was the
single vendor to a lot of packages that
people were relying on but of course a
single company can only produce packages
for a wider audience what about all
these niche
sub communities that require special
packages or maybe there's a research
group who is developing their own tools
and they want to distribute them to the
immediate circle of authors but they
couldn't just say hey anaconda can you
package this weird fortune stuff that
we've been doing you know because
so this was fixed by introducing a
platform where people users could upload
their own packages
it was called binstar later renamed to
anaconda.org it was 2014.
and so a lot of sub communities started
emerging around this service and they
were producing their own packages ios
bioconda cytos omnia astropy from as you
can see from different subcommittees in
scientific fields
this is nice everything's fixed right
well
many sub-communities
it had some problems
basically they were using
gonna be old an extension on that to run
the ci on a monorepo full of recipes so
every time you wanted to update
something you had to run everything but
travis ci and app failures things like
that were already i think back then
so
it worked for a small amount of packages
but in initially
when people had to contribute something
you wanted to give them permissions you
were giving them access to the full
thing
so some problems with the setup many
channels the application of effort some
packages were maintained in several
communities at the same time and even
more worrisome with subtle and
incompatibilities so you couldn't mix
and match
and at some point the scale of the
success was pushing the limits of the
cia the free
tire of ci services so you couldn't
build the full repo
the full channel in a single hour
and the permission stuff i mentioned
how was this fixed
well let's go to sci-fi 2015 there was a
sprint or something like that i'm not
really sure
but there was a key idea instead of
having all the recipes in one repository
what if we split that one recipe per
repository
ci limits are worked around and we can
have granular permissions for
collaborators
the only problem is that you need some
cross tooling needed so that's when
condesmithi was devised as the the tool
that could
generate the configurations unified
configurations across several
repositories
so basically a condensed method
repository is called a feedstock this is
the output of the tool and you will have
your conda recipe in there
and then the ci workflows the global
configuration and some supporting
scripts and metadata
so that was the emergence of canada
fortune 2015
and these are the foundational
principles we want to talk about
transparency compatibility automation
and distributed ownership since
everything is a github repo with pull
request and ci all the logs are there
for you to check if everything was built
correctly every package review and
change happens in public through a pr
request
and
as an extension to that the meeting
menus for the organization were also
like made available
the aspirations for compatibility is
that all the packages in the channel
should be installable together
and to make that happen we need to
maintain central avi pinning so things
can be built in the same way
of course after a number of packages you
cannot do this manually so automation is
key to make this happen
we will limit manual processes as much
as possible and automate the version
bumps the new migrations when the
opinions change
and especially when you have to fix
stuff
you only have to fix it in one place
then condensability will take place of
propagating the changes to the red the
rest of the feedstocks
since every repo is autonomous in that
way like it has everything they need to
operate um there's no single point of
failure in principle
except for one the stage recipes this is
the funnel to the ecosystem the entry
point
and yeah they can operate autonomously
in principle
this has been a huge success
uh it's actually quite interesting that
yesterday conor forge turned seven if
you look at the organization creation
date but it was yesterday the birthday
so happy the birthday candy forge
and some numbers to give you an idea of
and you have to put a k on most of them
so
three
thousand eight hundred maintainers
volunteers contributing packages to the
feedstock or helping and assistance 26
of those are active corps members and we
have
15 generous volunteers in the states
recipes repository this is these are the
people that review every recipe that
gets to
the ecosystem
16 000 repositories 17 000 package names
and i would suggest almost a million
artifacts
this is turbos that are this is growing
super fast six platforms
i don't know how many commits i don't
know how many issues and fears a lot of
them like really like just made by bots
most of the traffic is bots
fifth five terabytes of stretch at
anaconda is paying for thanks
and that's the bandwidth we use monthly
so key benefits of all of this we have a
standardized build environments you
don't have to
mess with your system to actually deploy
compilers and all the configuration of
the libraries
everything is either in a pre-configured
state through a docker image or there's
a preparation script to accommodate the
ci image for windows and mac os
and the control configuration is cross
repositories defined ones use it
everywhere kind of thing
and the pinnings for the important
packages like compiled libraries are api
hour
through like curation i'm checking on
the api laboratory and so on
the one feedstock
per recipe one repository per recipe
enables a better collaboration model in
my eyes so you have per package issue
trackers you have
reviews for every change in the pr you
have a history of what has happened to
that recipe and how that package has
produced what
what conversations were had years ago to
make this work in this way
so you can learn with very high degrees
of granularity and you can get focused
help or onboarding only on the parts of
the ecosystem that you want to work with
and
this separation of concerns leads to a
bigger unified community
i believe that in this case the sum of
those sub communities is bigger than
they were on their own individually
and as a side effect
we have an ever growing corpus of
knowledge and can afford like you have
all these recipes that are just build
scripts that you can check if you need
to do the same for another project or
something it's super useful and now with
the github code search stuff i don't
know if you're into that but
it works very nicely it's almost like
blackmagic
you can just cure the food ecosystem
those seventeen thousand recipes in
microseconds
milliseconds i won't be so excited it's
punishing me um so this allows us to
grow like programmatic insights as well
on the full ecosystem and yeah it's
it's a nice resource i believe so i like
to think about it like a build scripts
wikipedia
so yeah if you want to try i don't know
if you have access to ces.com
but things like that will give you all
the corpus of knowledge immediately
so
okay this is a lot of good things how is
it organized so these are the people
it's 100 committed driven there's no
full-time employee there
it's only people contributing their time
maybe with some help of a company the
core team we have eight emeritus members
that are no longer active the rest 26 of
us
are active you can see us in this corner
here
15 stage recipes volunteers and domain
specific head teams
again the numbers for maintainers and
repositories and also the army of bots
like there's a lot of automation i keep
discovering new services we have in
place like the bumper linters user
commands and requests you can create an
issue with a specific title and a bot
will do something for you
and that's like magic
and this is how it works so basically if
you want to start numpy it's already
there but what if you wanted to start
something else well you could be that
guy there start here you could submit a
pr to stage recipes
somebody a human will come and review if
it's following the best practices and
then what we expect out of quality from
that recipe and that will result in a
feedstock eventually when everything
passes
this will create the
kind of packages in ci services
generously provided by
these companies mostly microsoft
and
then the bot will perform some actions
and it will end up in anaconda.org first
through a staging channel so we can
review the artifacts in some automated
ways and eventually on the connectforge
channel itself
then cdi and sync will take place and
we'll propagate this to the rest of the
globe
that's for releasing your first package
but then there's a maintenance in place
like there's a heroku web services that
will
make sure that
everything is in sync with the global
configuration the migrations are taking
place or if a new pr is submitted that
we can actually make it past and still
confirm to to what the ecosystem is now
because everything is moving forward as
we speak
so that was my part i will now leave you
with what we will talk about growth
innovation
yeah
uh so i wanted to show some graphs uh
what the kind of forge growth looks like
to begin with and so here we see the
number of packages over time so those
are
individual package names
and
we can see quite a linear growth here
which is mainly limited by the amount of
reviewers on the stage recipes
to allow the creation of new feedstocks
and new packages
and then we have a bit more of an
exponential growth in the package
versions and platforms so each feedstock
can create multiple package versions and
also creates packages or package
artifacts for multiple different
architectures
and so you can really see that we have a
bit of a gross explosion here in the
number of published artifacts on conor
forge
if we look at
this graph by architecture we can see
for example that we have this no arch
which is really the most useful
architecture because it works on all
different architectures and that's
really taking over because we try to
convert as many as possible to to that
so it works immediately everywhere
and then down there you see the new os x
arm 64 which was a really successful
launch on condaforge where we were
really early was having packages that
run on the m1 chip
and it's already overtaking the linux
arm 64 architecture and so we can see
really nice growth on
and all these different architectures
and linux 64 is still
the easiest to build for and
our current leader
and if we look at the number of
downloads by channel
we see that some sometime in 2021
the conor forge channel overtook the
anaconda defaults channel in the number
of downloaded packages
and we peaked out of somewhere around
300 million downloads per month
which is quite a lot and also quite a
lot to handle for the anaconda
servers
and then we see
down there we have a bunch of other
popular channels so bioconda is the most
popular one but it only
has around 8 million downloads compared
to
300 of connor forge so it's it's quite a
large difference there
um so what are some of the growing pains
that we are facing
so um on the infrastructure side we have
many concurrent package bills that have
to be handled by
by the ci systems
we have something that's a bit uh
specific to the setup
behind anaconda.org there is a cdn for
the conor watch channel
and there's something that we like to
call cdn delay
which is the time from which the package
is uploaded to anaconda
and then is appears as downloadable from
the channel and that currently takes
around two hours which is a bit
frustrating sometimes if we are if you
want to build packages in a quick
succession
and then one of the infrastructural
challenges how we can manage all of this
repository and all of this metadata
without having to rebuild all the
packages
if there is some issue and i will talk
about that later
and then on the client side some of the
paints that we are facing is
that the repo data.json which is the
index of all the packages and all the
artifacts that are available from that
channel is growing and growing and
growing and currently just this indexing
file is around 120 megabytes of json
which is around 20 something megabytes
gzip but even that is pretty large if
you think about that it's just
downloading some like indexing data
and also all of these packages create a
huge solution space for the sat the
solvability so
the satisfiability solver that we run to
figure out what dependencies are needed
for a given package
um
and now um to elaborate a bit more
so
um we at conor forge we've burned
through a couple of ci services
and travis for example stopped working
for us drone also recently stopped
working for us
and circle ci
i have actually never seen
working but i think we still have
support somewhere
um and so currently we're really uh
yeah at the mercy of microsoft let's say
and they are really generous with us and
give us 200 parallel azure runners and
most recently since a couple of weeks we
also have 60 parallel github runners and
that's really what enables the corner
forge scale without that we'd be not
able to
sustain all these packages and package
bits
and for long running builds we're
currently investigating another solution
called ciron.io
where we can
on demand launch
instance on
some cloud vendors like aws or azure and
those can have more cpus
so more power because on the free
runners we are limited to two cores
and also
i think 72 hours of running time instead
of three hours that we are limited by by
the three tiers and for some packages
like cute or tensorflow they really long
run for a long time so we need that
to build everything in the cloud
sometimes these packages are built on
contributors laptops and that's not
great
and so one other thing on the
infrastructure side that we are doing
now is we have all of these automated
prs to the feedstocks
and now we check for solvability to
before we issue the pr because otherwise
sometimes
basically
we should be able to solve it based on
all the uploads but then we have to see
the end delay and then we would get all
the red check marks that we don't want
to see on the prs so we test that using
infrastructure beforehand
um so one thing that we are currently
working on
at quan stack
is to add more mirrors and mirror
support into the ecosystem
and the thing that we're currently
investigating is to use an oci registry
that is
a very simple storage solution
and github packages offer something like
that
to push all of the packages to and have
a mirror so that we could have multiple
mirrors to select from
and have it as a failover
and ideally this would also cut down on
the cdn sync times and allow for faster
rebuild times for example during
migrations
and
ideally we want to arrive at a state
where we have
linux style mirrors like ubuntu which is
mirrored at many universities and
telecom providers and things like that
and i think that would be a cool state
for conor watch to also have that kind
of infrastructure
there are some repo data workarounds in
place
so one is the current repo data json
which was innovated
for conda
and that contains only a smaller package
index which doesn't have all of the
package versions only the latest
versions of each package and any earlier
versions that are necessary for solving
for that package
and one other thing that we really need
at conor forge is the counterfeit repo
data patches
and what happens if for example
you don't specify an upper bound for
some dependencies but then that
dependency gets a new version released
which is not compatible
then back in the days you might have had
to rebuild the package and then push it
again to update the metadata but what we
can do is the wrapper data patching and
what which i think is a bit unique maybe
to
the way
the quanda ecosystem can operate
so with the wrapper data patching we can
change for example the upper bounds of
certain packages
to make sure that the solutions are
proper
and so that really helps with managing
all of uh dependencies and this rolling
release and if there are any
incompatibilities we can patch them over
basically on the fly
now one thing that we innovated on the
quan stack side is mamba
and mamba is
an improved
drop-in replacement for conda
and that uses the same cli arguments so
it's pretty compatible if you know conda
you can try mamba right away
and for mamba we're using c plus as an
implementation language for most parts
but still some python wrappers around
and
most importantly we had tried to use lip
soil for fast package resolutions and
that's the library that's also used by
opensuse and red hat in the rpm
ecosystem
and then lib curl for parallel downloads
and the archive for the extraction
and so the key difference between lip
solve and the way conda operates
is that lip solve is using a
backtracking satisfiability solver
and conda is doing a global optimization
scheme and this global optimization
at least from what i understand is one
of the things that
kind of makes conda a bit slow in
certain circumstances
and so we've had pretty nice successes
with using mamba
and
yeah
and now for remember we also won a cci
grant
that we wrote last year and that's
currently ongoing and there are some
additional things for scaling conor
forge in there so one thing is to use z
chunk for repo data which is also
something that comes from the rpm fedora
red head world
and z chunk allows for smaller repo data
download because you can download only
the necessary chunks to complete the
repo data bits that you already have
locally so only the updates are
downloaded
and then
there will also be support for mirrors
like i described before so we will have
mirror support with automatic fastest
mirror selection
oci registries and s3 buckets will be
natively supported
and there's ongoing work to use the
github ocr registry and all this is
implemented in another library that's
called currently called power loader
and then lib power loader and ideally
this can be reused by anybody who wants
to do something that looks like a
package manager
and one other thing that's necessary for
scaling further with confort is to have
better error messages
and pubgrap is another
dependency solver that we take some
inspiration from and they spend a lot of
time to think about error messages
and if the package repository grows in
size the error messages are also growing
its size because if you don't have a
really nice like algorithm to get error
messages it will just print out all the
versions that are not working and those
can be ten thousand or twenty thousand
and um that's not great so to make
make
make it efficient to work with kind of
watch we need better error messages
and then on the building side on the ci
we have some
new tooling one is condom mamba build
which is a drop-in replacement for
condor bit that's kind of monkey
patching condom built to use mamba or
lip number as a solver
and that's currently the default
behavior on corner foot
and then we are also working on
something that would be boa
which introduces a new recipe format
that uses pure mamba uh pure yummy and
mama as a solver and just a bit faster
as well
and to continue the growth we want to
scale out to more platforms
there are
different architectures and one exciting
ones is
m script in 32 which is webassembly
that we want to work on in the future
and we already support a lot of
programming languages but there are
other ecosystems that we'd like to
support better
julia zick and nim are some of the cool
hip languages that
could benefit from conor ford
and now janus will talk about the future
of the condo ecosystem
thanks
thanks wolf thanks timer i think this is
actually quite uh fascinating how much
technical bits and you know pieces four
day-to-day uh maintenance of conor forge
happen i wanna kind of step let's go one
slide back
first i want to say this uh it's kind of
a privilege to talk about this because i
just joined the contact community a year
ago approximately when i joined anaconda
and of course like just recovered it's
probably going to be incomplete but i
want to kind of point out that on the
conda development side like basically
the package manager itself we need to
kind of uh face the challenges that uh
the confort
project has so one thing of course i
wanted to highlight this graph here it's
kind of a graph of conda and conda build
issues over the years and as you can see
there's been a bit of a growth happening
there as well as similar to how
the larger conda and conor forge
ecosystem evolved
something that i felt in particular
fascinating is that how do we make sure
that while conda has been
historically a single vendor project and
maintained at anaconda we need to also
you know recognize that there are other
people working in this field and we need
to kind of find ways to collaborate on
this practically
and of course
one thing that is most important around
this is governance right how do we you
know as a as a
very flexible tool for catering to
different types of niches and in the
user bases how do we manage that
and find common common ground you know
building consensus
luckily conor forge has you know kind of
been a
trailblazer in that kind of regard
they've been much much better and
because of the needs of that diverse
group of people volunteering for this so
and i think in many ways conda has to
kind of catch up there you need also it
also needs to figure that out and
kind of
find find a kind of a common a common
topic a common concept to to governance
one thing that happened when i joined
last year that
reason why the conor team at anaconda
was rebuilt as well is that we
at anaconda
understand that those challenges you
know we want to kind of change the
maintenance strategy for conda to cater
to those new
needs in the community
which is defaulting to focusing focusing
on community support by default making
sure that we find common ground
and
one thing that is central to this and
maybe you know this from python is we
need to have a formalized process to
help make this happen in python it's a
pap process like the python enhancement
proposals
and for conda there was a kind of a
fledgling process there like that with
the conda enhancement proposals over um
a couple of years ago but it never
really took off and
that was one of the things that we
restarted last year to find a kind of to
have a process in place that when
community innovation happens that we can
kind of step back and make sure that all
those you know interesting ideas you
know can can actually make a production
system as well right so
long story short maintenance is a
process and i think we need to kind of
catch up for many many um reasons uh and
conda is doing like if you look in the
top right of that graph we're
having a dent and we are working towards
that basically catching up with all the
backlog i think that's really exciting
and i hope that it will help kind of
forge for example as well
um
more specifically of course mamba has
been a you know
incredible example of how community
innovation can help users like with
improved user experience just
being pretty lucky just faster and
and one thing that happened um last year
though is that we were basically looking
at the options that we have to kind of
get conda moving again and basically
restarting that that maintains a bit
better so one thing we thought what if
we basically took mamba or parts of it
and ported it over to conda and not in a
way that basically is
just back porting or copy pasting or
something like that but in a way that is
meaningful for the governance side as
well so we work together with uh
coinside and when i say we i mean
anaconda work together coinside to
take the lib mamba project which is the
library version of mamba and integrated
with conda we released that experimental
version earlier this year to kind of
gain confidence that the solutions that
this particular kind of solver this kind
of intermedia
step
would create the same solutions as conda
has previously or historically created
which is as you can imagine a pretty
important step for us to make sure that
all these users that expect a certain
behavior are not suddenly ending up with
a broken environment
uh with a program contact environment
and of course the uh my hope is that or
the contact teams at anaconda's hope is
that we use that experiment
first like eventually removing the
experiment label
from that package and eventually
making it a default or at least very
very easy to use for regular users
and finally i think i want to say this
is that i
i hope that this type of collaboration
between the various
communities people and organizations uh
can be a great example for future
collaboration actually making sure that
yes we have similar problems there were
similar
issues to kind of tackle and
if we work together we can actually find
common ground and create pluggable
systems to help this
of course like taking another step a
little bit back i wanted to
because there's just more more than just
this over of course in condom um
over the years and that's really uh
analog to the graph that you saw earlier
about the growth of complexity in conda
and conda build system we need to not
just on a governance side we also need
to place on a conda for the corner
development the technical challenges now
it's a code base that is almost 10 years
old so it's a it has kind of
accrued some craft it's let's put it
that way
and if we basically want to be
constructively engaging with community
innovation projects
i think the only way forward is some way
or form a plugin system that is very
easily
documented
very clearly documented it's explicit
and it's also
carrying
very clear dedication policies etc
something basically
has kind of happened over the past years
in conda there were some
parts of conda that were officially
treated as the
quote-unquote conda api but in fact
because of the complexity of the subject
matter of packaging
what really happened in the world in the
real world is that a lot of imports in
python happened all over the place from
the corner code base and that's really a
bummer let's put it that way because it
means that it's really really hard for
the konda team to
maintain like uh and having a consistent
story going forward so long story short
i think the plug-in api that europe is
considering right now is uh trying to
figure that out on a long term adding
specific endpoints into conda that
extend the or replace functionality in
it so that we can kind of move the
project forward
and
yet again a step backwards i want to say
this
i mentioned it before
conda forge definitely was a pioneer in
figuring out volunteer volunteer-based
project how do we basically
find common ground create rules around
it and make sure that things are not
breaking apart
because people are involved right so
they have a really great um set of tools
i mean they've of course that exists in
other projects as well but i wanted to
call out specifically the forge
enhancement proposal system for example
allowed it to scale and kind of to
actually handle the
various um
like needs that came with the growth
over the years and a code of conduct
system and that's really important i
think to kind of cater to all those
different types of
um
parts of the conda forge system uh
project is that it has separate project
teams that have their own um charter to
define so for example as was previously
said the stage recipes or the bot and
automation
teams
and i think
kind of
making the bridge back to conda i think
if we want to
move conda forward in terms of both
governance and technical debt we need to
um follow along right conor forge is a
great example there and we can we have
some similar mechanisms there the
contact incubator for example it's a
separate github organization that allows
projects that want to evolve basically
in the conda ecosystem make sure that
they are compatible um are um
exists and we have like a bunch of
projects there
and of course the kind of enhancement
proposals that i mentioned earlier
already
some of the projects that exist today
you know and those are just three of
approximately 80 uh projects that exist
right now that are built on top of
kundalini condor build and of course
including mamba et cetera
um
are those three like condelog system to
to create log files similar to poetry or
pip tools
or grayscale a tool a tool to
generate and maintain the contour
recipes that are required to to build
the packages in the first place and
finally
vendor-specific extensions such as setup
miniconda that allows regular users to
very easily set up content environments
in their github github actions runner
runners and that's just three of them to
showcase that it's a very diverse type
of tooling and projects
project area
so yeah that's a lot i know it's both
technical and governance that you need
to catch up on and i really
look forward to figuring this out
together with
this large ecosystem
in case you want to help
um of course this is about kanda forge
particular
if you're like adding new functionality
there is this stage recipe review team
it's a best place to get your feet wet
kind of to understand how do we package
uh
projects how does this work and what is
actually entailed with this it's it's
actually quite nice to to follow along
because you learn a ton about build
systems
if you want to uh basically quote
unquote keep things running there's a
ton of documentation or on our website
how to do this and i really would
encourage you to join our guitar channel
if you if you have any questions about
this
finally if you're into automation
the bot team is basically building bots
for automation all day and it's just
incredible how much
can be done by
when we use bots instead of humans
and of course and it's probably the
most important one if you want to
financially or in kind support condor
forge
point of forge is a non-focused fiscally
sponsored project which means you can
donate to none focus and it's earmarked
for the for the iconoforge project that
will allow us basically to pay for
credits on ci systems
et cetera et cetera so it's um it's a
quite fascinating thing and of course if
you have servers lying around or have
other means to do this feel free to give
us a pin
so yeah i think that's it uh
thank you for the for your attention and
i think you're ready for questions now
[Applause]
yeah thank you for the um for the talk
there are a couple of questions and the
first one
is the kind of forge build container
freely available to download for
building locally
so for linux you
you have the linux anvils for condaforge
they are available on docker hapa and
quay i think
for
windows we can't but there's a
recipe somewhere in an issue an output
request that you can use to build your
own windows image locally that should
standardize it as well but it's
basically installing the compilers for
you
and
os well there's a script that will help
you standardize where the sdk must be
installed but you have to take care of
things like homebrew getting in the way
or so so yeah for those cases maybe it's
better to run things in a ci
if you want to experiment
okay thank you
next question are corporate backed
packages like python tensor build a
tensorflow are built on free compute is
it possible to get them to contribute
compute resources
so pytorch and tensorflow are currently
built on
contributors computers basically because
they take too long to build on ci
systems
and what we are trying to do right now
is to
get someone to sponsor some credits for
aws or azure or some service like that
where we can use ci run io to
run the builds
um we don't have direct contact as far
as i know to the pythorg or tensorflow
team
but if they would like to sponsor those
credits we'd be very grateful
okay then we need to get them at high
data
next question do you support fortran as
extension language
yes
it was easy are there projections or on
how many downloads will be served in the
next five to ten years
okay
so the forecast if you see the number of
downloads is growing faster
never trust an exponential plot that's
something we have learned
so yeah it's going to be more we can
assume but the growth of packages is
surprisingly linear like a number of
package names
so
you can argue why but maybe stage
recipes the entry point is about a neck
of growth in that case that's why it's
linear but well we don't know but it
will grow
okay then there's another one
um
there's the question um why not choose
why not just use pie pie and the python
packaging stack is corner forge always
better when is it better to use pip
okay
okay those are three questions
so
so i think it's perfectly reasonable for
c python to be packaged separately so
let's be clear i think that's one thing
um what does help is kind of forge of
course does not just bring the python
stack it also brings like all the
i think i don't know the all the
alternatives like all the packages that
are
needed if you want to run a full stack
real world environment i think that's
that's really a challenge and i think
everyone has set up python environments
here in one way or another and has
struggled to figure that out can't
afford is just basically another way of
making it kind of
uh completely out of the box kind of
situation and yeah i mean i don't i
don't mind other ways doing this i'm a
pip developer originally so that's fine
yeah i hope that you can maybe add
something to that so
real strength is once you start mixing
programming languages like r
ruby rust python
then you get all of the dependencies
that you need from conor forge
and pipe ui obviously can only serve to
the python crowd
and so yeah the real strength is once
you have more difficult dependencies
more difficult things like tensorflow
which also uses c plus plus
and you want to combine tensorflow with
something else and yeah that's where the
power comes in
okay then there's another one
correct me if i'm wrong but it seems all
packages are built centrally do you see
this being a limit or future bottleneck
at some point
but
the infrastructure is built so we don't
depend on a single provider although in
function yeah
functionally we are very dependent on
azure right now but the infrastructure
is prepared to actually
burn through ci providers as we have
seen so you can redeploy connectforge
you can build your own forge with the
tooling we have
some people do this for specific
projects you have if you look for forge
something organizations you will find
some
you can render a feedstock yourself so i
don't think it's tied to the central
infrastructure although in practice it
looks like that but it's made to be like
really playable so i don't think that's
a risk
okay thank you so much and thanks for
the amazing talk and your work thank you
[Applause]